Newton's first law tells us that an
object at rest will stay at rest and an
object in it with a constant velocity
will keep having that constant velocity
unless it's affected by some type of net
force or you actually could say an
object with constant velocity constant
velocity will stay having a constant
velocity unless it's affected by a net
force because really this takes into
consideration the situation we're not
due to rest you could just have a
situation where the constant velocity is
zero so Newton's first law you're gonna
have your constant velocity it could be
zero it's gonna stay being that constant
velocity unless it's affected unless
there's some net force that acts on it
so that leads to the natural question
how does a net force affect the constant
velocity or how does it affect the state
of an object and that's what Newton's
second law gives us so Newton's Newton's
second law second law of motion second
law of motion and this one is maybe the
most famous although they're all kind of
famous actually I won't I won't pick
favorites here but this one gives us the
famous formula force is equal to mass
times acceleration an acceleration is a
vector quantity and force is a vector
quantity
and what it tells us because we're
saying okay if you apply force it might
change that constant velocity but how
does it change that constant velocity
well let's say I have a brick right here
and it is floating in space Newton's
second law tells us and it's pretty nice
for us that the laws of the universe or
at least in the classical sense before
Einstein showed up the laws in the
universe actually dealt with pretty
simple mathematics what it tells us is
is if you apply if you apply a net force
if you apply a net force let's say on
this side of the object and we talk
about net force because if you apply two
forces that cancel out and then have
zero net force then the object won't
won't change its constant velocity but
if you have a net force applied to one
side of this object then you're going to
have a net acceleration going in the
same direction so you're going to have a
net acceleration going in that same
direction and what Newton's second law
of motion tells us is that acceleration
is proportional to the
or supplied or the force applied is
proportional to that acceleration and
the constant of proportionality or to
figure out what you have to multiply the
acceleration by to get the force or what
you have to divide the force by to get
the acceleration is called mass that is
an object's mass that is an object's of
mass and I'll make a whole video on this
you should not confuse mass with weight
and I'll make a whole video on the
difference between mass and weight mass
is a measure of how much stuff there is
now that we'll see in the future there
are other things that we don't normally
consider stuff that does start to have
mass but for classical or at least a
first-year physics course you could
really just imagine how much stuff there
is weight as we'll see in a future video
it's how much that stuff is being pulled
down by the force of gravity so weight
is a force mass is telling you how much
stuff there is and this is really neat
that this formula is so simple because
maybe we could have lived in a universe
where force force is equal to mass
squared times acceleration times the
square root of acceleration which would
have made all of our math much more
complicated but it's nice it's just this
constant of proportionality right over
here it's just this nice simple
expression and just to get our feet wet
a little our feet wet a little bit with
computations involving force mass and
acceleration let's say let's say that I
have a force and then D and the unit of
force is appropriately called the the
Newton so let's say I have a force of so
let's say that the force I have a force
of 10 Newtons and just to be clear a
Newton is the same thing so this is the
same thing as 10 kilogram meters per
second squared and that's good that a
Newton is the same thing as kilogram
meters per second squared because that's
exactly what you get on this side of the
formula so let's say have a force of 10
Newtons and it is acting on it is acting
on a mass let's say that the mass is 2
kilograms and I want to know the
acceleration I want to know the
acceleration I want to know the
acceleration and once again in this
video these are vector quantities
if I have a positive value here I'm
going to we're going to make the
assumption that it's going to the right
if I had a negative value then it would
be going to the left so implicitly I'm
giving you not only the magnitude of the
force but I'm also giving you the
direction I'm saying it is to the right
because it is positive so what would be
the acceleration well we just use F
equals MA you have on the left hand side
10 Ukiah I could write 10 Newton's here
or I could write 10 kilogram meters per
second squared and that is going to be
equal to the mass which is 2 kilograms 2
kilograms times the acceleration times
the acceleration and then to solve for
the acceleration you just divide both
sides by 2 kilograms so let's divide the
left by 2 kilograms let's divide the
right byte or let me do it this way
let's divide the right by 2 kilograms
that cancels out the 10 and the 2 10
divided by 2 is let me just do it 10
divided by 2 is 5 and then you have
kilograms cancelling with kilograms your
left hand side you get 5 meters per
second squared and then york that's
equal to your acceleration now just for
for fun what happens if i double what
happens if i double that force well then
i have 20 Newtons well i'll actually
work it out then i have 20 kilogram
meters per second squared
kilogram meters per second squared is
equal to i don't have to color-code this
2 kilograms times the acceleration
divide both sides by 2 kilograms divide
both sides by 2 kilograms and what do we
get cancels out 20 divided by 2 is 10
kilograms cancel kilograms and so we
have the acceleration in this situation
is equal to 10 meters per second squared
is equal to the acceleration so when we
double the force we went from 10 Newtons
to 20 Newtons the acceleration doubled
went from 5 meters per second squared
and to 10 meters per second squared so
we see that they are directly
proportional and the mass is that how
proportional they are and so you could
imagine what happens if we double the
mass
if we double the mass and let's say in
this situation with 20 Newtons then we
won't be dividing by 2 kilograms anymore
we'll be dividing by 4 kilograms and so
then we'll have 20 divided by 4 which
would be 5 and there would be meters per
second squared so if you make the mass
larger if you double it then your
acceleration will be half as much so the
larger the mass you have the more force
you need to accelerate it or go for a
given force the less that it will
accelerate it the harder it is to change
its constant velocity